I'm coaching so I'm not gonna pick
myself and just lay that out right now
yo what's up this employee Smith here by
the picking off the top five team but
before we get started I got to talk to
you about this Heather door right here
this right here it's good for all kinds
of drinks you ought to try it
Top Chef margaritas all those things
I've made great with this tequila try it
I'm gonna put it down right now and then
we'll go to my team my first selection
I'm gonna start with my defense because
it because they say defense wins
championships right so with that said
I'm going defense the end Reggie White
and Bruce Smith we're coming at the
quarterback then after that I got to get
a quarterback because I gotta get some
points the best in the game Tom Brady
I'm gone there then after that we're
gonna have to have a safety to stop
somebody to run the rocks
running luck not going to living crap
out of somebody then after that we got
to have somebody but for this guy to
throw the ball to the one and only get
rice those are my five I mean I could
have went here I could have wind there
is our line baguette but I only got five
picks so they say defense wins
championships I think I'd go with
defense if you can't run and you can't
throw the ball we're getting the ball we
get the ball these two they gonna put up
a lot of points from here my picks I'm
going my quarterback Tom Brady going my
defense a in Reggie White the Minister
of Defense and on another side my big
brother Bruce Smith DB is running lot
hard hitting you come across the middle
gonna knock you out and how can I leave
Worrell out the best wide receiver in
the game